before you get mad at me the things i
say just honestly
be alone and hear what i said because i
know from experience
and i know what i'm talking about
so hear me out and don't just blow up my
dms with hate
i don't hate women and i don't hate men
i love allah more
than i love anything else and every day
i work harder alhamdulillah and you
should do
i mean
[Music]
[Music]
you don't feel like it's a burden to
take care of your mom
because deep down you care about your
mom and you wouldn't want to see her
in this position you wouldn't want to
see her suffer because no one else is
going to take care of her
well i mean simply just tell you yeah
you're sitting like yo
how would you feel if mom passed away
knowing you didn't do anything to take
care of her
salaam alaikum warahmatullahi welcome
back to the realest podcast in the
dhonia
it's your boys from t3m and we are
joined with a very special guest today
sister milan
how you doing fast alone good good
alhamdulillah
so real quick for the viewers that don't
really know much about
you or your mission tell us a little bit
about your journey
so the reason i really started getting
interested in islam
was because i didn't really understand
relationship
issues so seeing a lot of
broken families and being part of a
broken family and not really having a
sort of strong
father figure i started looking for
the islamic perspective and i know you
guys have had some disagreements in the
past
with uh two of the people i'll mention
but alhamdulillah
i think we're all past that but one of
the biggest influences was habib
the mma fighter and the way he responded
to conor mcgregor because
i was more rowdy and loud and kind of
you know a little bit arrogant a little
bit arrogant and when i saw how habib
was more stoic the islamic type of
discipline with your tongue i had a
shift and then that got me to go down
a more deeper islamic perspective of
relationships and you know the way in
which you carry yourself with character
and i came across the older videos of
multimank um i know he's different now
different energy but i looked at his
younger videos and
said huh what is this and i started
going more down the path of like
discovering what islam was
and i started to study islam and then i
started to get a lot of great people
part of the channel who knew way more
than me and
they recommended books and that really
pushed me further and further and then
there's different moments at that point
of junction where
i started realizing and recognizing the
signs that islam is the religion for me
and i went further and further and
further and then i had very interesting
dreams
and then i became closer and closer to
islam and i said my shahada
and each day i study and each day i
do the fasting and follow the rules and
start to understand faith
and listening to the scholars like
it just really just showed me like wow
and as i've many have on my channel who
follow me
but your audience might not know i've
studied a lot of religions i was an
atheist for a while
um i have a past of studying so when i
finally came to islam
i was like this is it you know ah there
we go
this is oh where was this it's a
completely different type of energy
wisdom
and before you know it here i am and
ah it's just it's amazing it's
everything had to happen for it to be
the way it was
but no one can tell me that you only
chose islam because you were born to it
or you haven't studied anything else you
know the typical
rebuttals that people will give and it's
like no actually i uh
i'm very familiar with all the other
ones and i've read
countless religious texts and had deep
discussions with ministers and
baptist types and methodists and
buddhists and
very darwinist type of atheists so i am
very versed in
philosophy theology rhetoric and other
systems but
islam it just hit me in a totally
different way
and yes so that's a a very concise
summer
summary of what led me to islam
before we go into uh some deeper
questions for some more insight
um compared to when you first got into
islam
how do you think you have changed oh
well my my temper number one i
because i grew up in philly was very
quick uh
to to get to fight you know because i'm
very good in martial arts so
i used to do a lot of fighting i just
you said something is 10 seconds it was
like okay
right now you know and uh islam got me
to be no no you can't do that you have
to be disciplined
control your emotions control your anger
watch your mouth you don't always have
to be the loudest one in the room to
show your
your force you can be reserved you can
be restricted you can
lead by example and islam has gotten me
to the point where i am
way less impulsive way less impulsive
now it's more difficult
for me to even get the urge to just get
really venomous
because when you grow up around a lot of
you know
quick reactions due to anger it's harder
to restrain yourself
and that's how habib the mma fighter
really
kind of inspired me because i was like i
didn't even know that was possible
you know i thought you had to kind of
always respond always just like okay
quick
zero to 100 right now and show you and
dominate you and put you in your place
but habib was like he just sat there and
was like collected while conor was you
know dancing around
and insulting his wife insulting his
religion just
saying things that i myself if someone
said to me
would have gotten up already and i was
like why does he do that and so many
people on the channel were like
because he's a muslim and i was like
this is islamic masculinity
and they're like yeah this is islamic
masculinity i was like really
because i grew up around christians and
mormons who are more softer men
they have their suits their shoulders
are very petite
it's not the kind of force but when i
saw something so like
iron like like a pillar just sitting
there i was like he's not even like what
is going on
that's amazing so that's one change and
then the urge for modesty because
many on the channel know but some of
yours might not is that my mother was a
adult entertainer and i my father
was a man who dated a lot of women in
the adult entertainment industry
so i saw a lot of adulting
content in my life and
i didn't have a sense of modesty
or respect for modesty i didn't really i
thought
i thought of it as like you know your
oppression
right like why are they cover up this is
weird you need to show all the time
you have to peacock you get to
constantly putting yourself out there
but islam got me to understand and enjoy
modesty and that was something like
wow you know because it works as a
process the more i studied the hadith
the more times i read the quran
the more i settled down the more i
controlled my anger
it didn't the same compulsion wasn't
there and it was like a peeling away
of you don't have to it's like
deprogramming in a way
you're reshaping yourself so the modesty
factor came in
controlling my anger and patience
being steadfast and the whole concept of
your suffering is a trial
from allah whether you have bounty or
whether you're restricted
you will be rewarded in his life
or in the hereafter but either way you
have to have patience gracious patience
and there's no complaining you deal with
it you praise allah
under every condition you move forward
there's no wallowing in your own
self-pity
and that really made me feel like wow
like because
i'm not the victimhood card is very
popular right now
the more victimized you are the higher
status you get
and even though there's a lot of
suffering in my life this
changed my psychology where i was like
okay so anything that happens to me
you must endure and wait for a respite
from allah
and it just shifts the way in which you
deal with trauma or bad
circumstance and cautious of when you
have something good like okay it can
come
it can go anytime don't grasp it and be
addicted to it so
just watch how you deal with good things
and bad things
and to press forward so that's another
way so i would say patience
the suffering angle and modesty
controlling my anger
and materialism i mean the material is
the angle because i'm sure you know
the american consumerist culture right
buy the cars buy this title worship and
i started to
peel it back i don't need this brand i
don't need
you know this networking group i don't
need this title
i need to focus on the hereafter i need
to focus on doing good deeds having
patience
giving saka myself some fasting
i need to study and then i got so all my
energy just kind of shifted
towards studying islam being healthy
cutting out
bad friends cutting out the drinking
cutting out any type of party lifestyle
just it just really started coming down
and then enjoying that change
so islam has changed me
i mean just a whole new person to the
point where people
mention it you know and my my family is
pretty happy pretty happy because they
were worried i'm the first muslim in the
family
so they're christians and mormons and so
they were like
islam better be careful because they
have stereotypes from the television
you know they never met a muslim so
they're like what does this mean like
where are you going you're gonna leave
where are you going it's like no and
they just see the change and they're
like oh wow
it's like if they can see it you know
others are saying it and i see within
myself so those are some of the bullet
points of
how islam has changed me and i know the
other two might have a couple questions
i know i got a lot so i'm just going to
get them all out there
but my first one is how do you think or
how did your parents
or just those around you how did they
really take
you coming into some i know you briefly
went over how they had these
preconceived notions
but how has that changed where where are
they at right now
well as i mentioned my father is a
freemason and he is into the occult
and he told me
muhammad peace be upon him isn't real
that
satan is not who we think he is
that um muslims worship the black box
just like the jews and then he went into
a kind of a conspiracy
rabbit hole he was not what is satan
what is satan then back for cutting you
off but
to him according to his that's a long
story about luciferianism
this sort of torchbearer of knowledge
who set humans free according to them
they don't see him as an oppressor or a
trickster or someone to be worried about
but someone who
relieves you of your restraints and
allows you to
bring forth a sort of raw self-will
i'm summarizing it but that's their view
in a nutshell so he was more remember
and he also had a lot of women
he has a lot of women so modesty to him
is not
you know he has billy dancer girls so
when he saw me in my
modesty thing it's like to him it's like
abnormal do you know what i'm trying to
say it's like him is like
[Music]
because when you deal with someone his
values are not islamic
his values are islamic so he was not as
receptive
but i but i was i stuck to my
mind by my points you know and one day
if me and him can have a longer
conversation
the more i study islam i'll be able to
interact with his occultism more and be
able to explain
the differences and more merits of the
truth of islam
my mother on the other hand she was more
receptive
because she was like oh masculine men
he was an adult entertainment industry
and he said to me
well many of that descent who are more
islamic are more fortified
they are more masculine american men are
fresh i don't know she had a joke you
know and i was like okay well
she was like they're soft they're this
they're they're addicted to this this
because she was in the
entertainment injuries she had a lot of
customers so she was able to give me
another perspective
and for her she was pleased but she just
was worried about like don't
get one that is abusive right because
she knows i don't have a partner
so she was like don't just make sure
that if you get a muslim man that he's
an
actual muslim not one pretending to be
one i think you know what i'm saying
right
how some have like a different vibe
where they don't pray their salah
they're just like a muslim of show so
she was worried don't get a fake one
make sure you get one that actually has
done their pilgrimage that's studied
someone who will follow the rules just
they're very good just be careful
and she she asked me a lot of questions
about the modesty aspect and then i had
a whole
really deep conversation with her and
she said i understand
your compulsion for modesty i understand
i'm older now she was telling
me and i uh i enjoy the modesty aspect
now that i'm older because when she was
younger obviously
she was not modest at all right being
filmed being seen by men
revealing her body having a long career
in that
modesty was not something she made money
off of let's put it that way
but for her children like for me she was
quite pleased
and she could tell how you know the
islamic mindset had calmed me down
she was like oh great you know and then
my grandfather
he's a veteran he was a soldier of
vietnam he's a christian but he at the
same time he was like oh good
hard-working man like he he didn't say
much
but he didn't criticize and then my
grandmother
she has a little dementia she's a mormon
and she said honey i'm just glad you
have god
and i said okay thanks grandma and then
like that's all she says like honey i'm
just happy you know because she's really
old
and she didn't criticize and so yeah i
mean
and also with my younger brothers
they're getting to the age where they're
becoming very handsome
and i've been uh trying to talk to them
about islamic male masculinity
and like hey you don't have because
their dads are dead uh
they were drug dealers and they're
they're they were killed they're dead so
they don't have a father figure
and so i'm trying to introduce them
slowly into islam
like getting them interested and that's
why i think i've been getting more on
this point of the islamic male
masculinity because i'm worried about my
brothers
because um they're my both my parents
remarried african americans so
i worry about him there's a big push on
femininity in the blackmail community
and they're good looking and i'm worried
about them i'm very very worried like
with the propaganda of like little gnaws
and
the stuff that they're doing so my
family's been very receptive now with my
uncle who was
he's more of a fundamentalist christian
he's a
he was a sunday school teacher i haven't
had the opportunity to talk to him
yet but i know he won't be receptive but
at least
on a dialogue angle i will be able to
exchange scholarly
uh back and forth with him on why jesus
is in god
and you know why the trinity is not
really conceptually valid
and that day will come but he's not
on the list yet to talk to but everyone
else besides my father has been
supportive
so you know what let's just rewind a bit
i want you to get into that you don't
need to
tell us the whole you know deep
philosophical conversation you had with
your mom on modesty
but maybe some cliff notes so speak to
the woman that's watching that's
falling for this feminist [ __ ] and
she's out here thinking that she needs
to commoditize her body
to make it into dunya also talk to the
girl that's maybe coming into islam kind
of learning about modesty
and then also maybe to the the girl
that's already
muslim but she's struggling with hijab
okay so one of the main points about
modesty what's beautiful with islam is
that
you cut off the dependency and addiction
to the male gaze
and you become less self-hating
because being around a lot of adult
entertainment women types
the more they show the more dead you
become inside
you more you become alienated from your
own consciousness so one of the things
my mother would talk about
when we when i asked her about her
career about the type of psychology
that's needed
the more you keep showing your body the
more
men you sleep with the more you need to
have intoxicants
upon you in order to do what you have to
do
because you start to change the way you
look at men you see them as just like
this
this they have the thing between their
pants i'll get the job done
they give me the money get out next
take a shower because they would take a
shower after
and uh next one next one
the more you have yes you learn how to
please them
you learn how to do it effectively and
you'd get the job done as they say but
you become more
and more dead inside and you get less
satisfied
with the men that you're seeing and you
actually start to resent them
you see them as these base pumping
gorilla
just give me the money like you start to
almost hate them
and then you start when you start to
hate the male energy
you start to want to dominate them when
you start to dominate them
you start to vampirize them when you
vampirize them with their energy
you want to abuse them you start seeking
power in a very dark way
and then you start to become less
nurturing
then you see kids as an annoying burden
and then when the kids become annoying
burden you become more cold when you
become more cold
you need to loosen up a bit with drugs
then the drugs come in and then you
start
your personality starts becoming more
schizophrenic
and then when you're more schizophrenic
you start to become more nihilistic
you become more nihilistic you become
more self-loathing
and then you need to buy something and
then you buy this stuff
that she would say you'd buy all this
stuff and it the shoes the perfume the
jewelry the flowers
everything it just nothing was hitting
and then she moved into crack
she was like because she became a drug
addict and then
it was a mess because you just keep
going down down and down and then at a
certain point
you're so mentally damaged from just
using men
that you can no longer see the goodness
in men
the weak virtuous men like the christian
or mormon she would describe
you'd see them as like i'll just smash
you i'll peg you
i'll just oh i'll crush your testicles
and then when you get a dominant man
you almost want to destroy him like the
epic of gilgamesh i don't know if you
read it but ishtar
was a was a quote-unquote goddess it's
like a 10 000 year old tale
and you almost want to take those
masculine men's heads as a trophy
as sort of like i crushed him i
submitted him
i got him i put a color on him that's
what the dominatrix stuff is because she
was also a dominatrix
so the more dark and sickly
you become and the more vain and vapid
you become you also want to alter your
body to compete with the younger women
so the plastic surgery comes in
right you say i'm gonna fix my boobs
this year i'm gonna do my lips
and the more you submit to a doctor and
pay him money that you got from your
customers
to beautify you to create you
you start to get sick also because of
the pills because
the oxycontin oxytocin percocet
vicodin these pills they give you they
also affect you
they make you sick you have withdrawals
you throw up
and so when they look in the mirror
without any makeup and they're not
all princessed out they hate what
they've done they have flashbacks
constantly in their head of all the
different customers you get a sort of
ptsd
you push out those bad flashing images
you use drugs
and then you get a text like okay next
customers here we'll see you at nine
o'clock
uh you your opening spot for this uh you
know dance is gonna be
from this time to this time bring x and
x outfit
uh they're gonna pay this much you
really start to become just like ah
and you become much more weighed down
and then just to sleep
oh geez just to sleep it's like it's
horrible that they would describe
so i would tell these young muslim girls
is that the more additions you add on
the more of your money your spend
you are literally just like a dairy cow
what happens to a dairy cow
it gets pregnant it gets milked the male
calf becomes veal
eventually the female cow after she
can't make milk anymore
she's sent off to the slaughterhouse the
bones are sold
the the organs are sold the height is
sold
you're pieced apart everyone making
money off the dairy cow
when you work in the sex industry you're
on only fans you're doing all this stuff
you are a dairy cow and worse also is
that you begin to hate yourself and sex
no longer has
the the beautiful angle to it anymore
and it makes you resent men
hate yourself and you get this really
horrible
nasty ego of like oh more validation you
get from the male gaze the more cycle
they become
it's like oh i know i'm beautiful i know
i'm this and it's like you're so nasty
you're so mean you're so
vain you're so ugh there's a there's a
sharpness to your tongue it's like
you're so manipulative and lying
and you only care about going out and
it's like
they can't stay home and they spend all
their dudes money
it's like no wonder why no good man
wants them because a good guy
he gets that energy that those women
vibrate and feed off of
is not normal they become abusive and
once they start drinking a lot
they smack their men they hit their men
way
more quick to fight so quick to fight i
mean
these girls they start out really good
but the pimp dresses
a real pinterest man i've been around
them they just
that's a scary woman man that's a scary
woman because it's like it's their
business to take you as a good girl
and to fill you so many times with men
that you no longer
are even who you are and the way they
can manipulate you and call your
psychology you're not gonna like it
muslim girls you're not gonna like it
you're gonna hate yourself
and you're gonna regret what you did and
intimacy
is not that hard to learn when you like
somebody it comes out what they're
to teach you yes you'll get skills
but when it really will matter you're
going to be blocked inside because
you're going to need a substance to
to get active to get warmed up and that
substance is going to pollute your womb
it's going to affect your hormones it's
going to affect your metabolism
and it's going to drain your wallet and
you know these drug dealers
they're going to pedal your drugs to you
they're going to want a piece of you too
if you don't have the money because you
know you spent it right you've maxed out
your credit cards you don't have a
couple customers for a while
they're gonna say okay you can't pay me
the money i want something else and then
she's gonna hate herself for having to
constantly give her body to people for
validation
it starts with only fans it starts with
tinder it starts
and these pinterest says they're smarter
than these girls they
want to take the virtuous young girls
the fresh immigrants the young girls who
are innocent whose parents have guarded
them
because that's the flavor that's the
menu that's the price for them
the men who who i've met and who i've
been around and my father being of those
types
they want a fresh girl who hasn't been
broken in yet
and some of them specifically want a
girl who's very innocent
and they're gonna break her down and
pass her around
with five dudes on one girl and she and
these pimpers are gonna tell her
hey this is gonna be fun and have fun
we're gonna have fun come on come on
come on just have a little martini have
a little pills
he's gonna be all right you know you do
he's fun relax we got music we got food
come on just go upstairs
and the girls when they do the walk of
shame as they call it in the morning
the makeup's messed up they stink like
all these different guys
a lot of these girls report crying in
the shower
they have like a feeling inside of like
a gap
and they're tender down there they're
not gonna like it
and once they heal from that then they
can go harder next time
and harder next time and harder and
harder and harder and before you know it
once they get a reputation as soon as
they get in the car with a john
he's gonna say like i heard about you i
don't have to treat you well
you know the pimp culture is extreme
and the way hollywood makes it the way
the strippers make it
remember a lot of them are on drugs it's
one of these a lot of innocent muslim
girls don't realize the makeup hides it
the jewelry hides it
the ugliness of what goes on in those
rooms
would break their parents heart and it's
going to be filmed it's going to be
uploaded people will try to blackmail
you
and they will try to get you to sell
yourself for a price and you can start
high
when you're pure right you had like
maybe 10 dudes your whole life
okay you can get 150 bucks maximum 500
right but the more you get the lower
your price goes
unless you become a fetish person a
dominatrix type
and let me tell you you go into that
field you're not gonna
you're you're you're done you're done
the things that those men request
you're not gonna be able to go to sleep
and forget it let's put it that way
and these girls have no idea what
they're getting into there is no
i'm scared i don't consent i want to go
home like the feminist liberals say
they always no when you get there the
camera's on
there is no i'm gonna turn it off there
is excuse me we booked you
you're gonna do your job and they have
much stronger women to come in and coax
you oh honey you're scared come here
come here come here
here here here here here take this oh
just this one honey oh next time it'll
be so much better
and then they coax them these women they
know what to do
and you trust them because they have big
boobs like they have like they have on a
sort of pool come on come on honey come
on we won't tell anybody your mom
doesn't know
it's okay it's okay come on now they
have different psychological ways they
get them
and then they have like a really
handsome guy there too is a little bit
more of like
hey come on and then those girls they're
like
they do it and eventually they're like
they get more tough as they say
and then that's when you're gonna get
the weirdos that's when you're gonna get
the guy from wall street who says
honey i paid 500 i'm going to
get my 500 don't you want that new bag
come on i'll take you for a ride in the
ferrari
what's the big deal it's not a big deal
and then they
they push them they push them they push
them and before you know it
these girls are so traumatized with ptsd
they have mental illness they have
chronic depression
they have anxiety you know and the
constant judging of their bodies
causes anorexia it causes us
disfigurement
in this mirror where they're like who am
i what am i
they become so sick and then you tell
them like in islam
you you do do so you don't wear the
makeup if you do it properly right
you break free from that oh i'm gonna
cover my beauty save it for my man
that's powerful it's so powerful because
no one can vampirize on you no one can
judge you or manipulate you
or say oh honey you should put this
shadow of eye shadow oh honey you should
do your contouring like this
change your hair color this way do this
do this do this do this
no i'm gonna do this what i have to do
for permanent ability
for my salah my dedication is to islam
i am not gonna be a dairy cow for you
i'm not going to the slaughterhouse i'm
not going to the brothel and i'm going
to listen to my imam i'm not going to
listen to the pimp dress
islam is a very powerful tool when i the
more i study it the more i learn
it will save you from the trauma because
cardi b
nicki minaj all these women they don't
talk about the
loneliness and mental illness that they
get or the dangers that come
from marketing yourself like a piece of
meat like that
because when the door closes that's when
the danger comes so that's my what i
would say to the muslim girls
is that stop now while you're ahead
you're going to get a customer who's
going to
fracture your brain there is there's
going to be things they're going to ask
you to do
and at first you might say no you say
okay i'll give you 200. no
no 300. 500.
you're like 500. oh geez and that's how
it gets in
but then when you got the money and they
toss it at you they toss the money at
you
when you leave that place and you go
home and you take a shower
here you it's in your head forever i
just want to add something
real quick that um before you go on that
a lot of people are listening by now
they're probably disliking they're
probably commenting and they're gonna
they're gonna be like okay it's not that
bad
or what do you mean not every girl does
this here's the thing
what what sister milan is talking about
it could start from
just being hooked into instagram
validation it could be you
needing attention seeking people in your
dms it's not gonna have to be a
transactional thing where you meet a guy
in a hotel
guys it literally starts with the basic
fundamentals of
internet modesty not really having that
in check then only fans oh it's not that
bad
and every single girl i know that's down
that road
and i'm sure most of these girls might
know some of these girls they're
suffering they're suffering from
tens or you know dozens of mental
illnesses they're on meds
and they're just not happy with
themselves they're very insecure
and they're just come on it's like a
breeding ground for jen
for the shaya team and what islam is
trying to do what the sister is trying
to say
is you know islam provides you
an escape and from this dunya from the
shackles of
this materialistic feministic
post-modern world
yes yes you see why they insecure
is because when the male gaze looks at
you or the female because you will have
to do lesbian actions eventually
eventually you will have to be bisexual
there is no oh i only
gonna be straight no no no you do what
you're paid to do
and once you allow the money in that
money will make you walk
the money will make you talk you'll be a
slave
to paper you really literally and
they'll get insecure because they'll be
like you know what your boobs aren't the
shape i want
these customers will tell you no you
know what can you wear a wig
i don't really like your hair color uh
can you put some contacts on can you
make your eyes blue
can you put in some vampire teeth they
will change you
oh can you wear you know is there a
possibility for you to uh you know
fix your nose a little bit you know what
i i don't really like your length of the
hair
can you cut it well can you wear you
know like they just start to tell you
what to do
and the more you start to become a
circus performer
that's when you're gonna start getting
more alienated because you'll be like
oh i gotta wear all these costumes i
gotta perform and and i i'm not heated
up because some men they're not going to
touch you
and warm you up they're going to say
right now not all men
are going to be like this 50 shades of
gray
oh i'm going to talk nice to you i'm
going to give you food and wine no
sometimes it's going to be
the door's closed do what i said here i
got an outfit for you here
dressed like a dog here here's a snake i
want you to put it on your body while i
touch you
all types of perversions come in and
there is you know like it's just
you cannot control it when the avalanche
is coming you think i'm going to be
strong
i'm so special i can resist
these psychologists these pinteresters
they've been at the game longer than you
they've been at the game longer than you
you think you're the first girl
to be like i'm not gonna be a big [ __ ]
i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna go with the nice guys who
are handsome it's gonna be a guy with a
fast stomach
who's balding who's like
smells like cheese you know it's not
always going to be the handsome guy
and money if you got a skinny dude like
from wall street
or one who works in the financial
district and he says i'll give you a
thousand dollars
and she's like what a thousand dollars
for an hour and he's like but you here's
his list
and then you look at and you're like
okay this is cool this is cool oh my
gosh what
and then that's when the pinterest comes
in with the drugs drugs will make you
do things that you will be so
embarrassed about
and they say well i won't need drugs oh
honey you're going to need drugs once
you have a couple johns
these these girls think that they can
tell a customer what they want
that's what you think in the beginning
but i know from experience
hiring my mother and meeting these
stripper women honey
you you ain't got no power over a man
who runs a brothel
it's his job to tell women
you know what they got to do and they
know exactly how to do it and some of
them
some of the girls they'll be a handsome
guy that'll get them in
he will give her really good intimacy in
bed
and he will totally dominate her in an
unhealthy way not the healthy kind right
and he will he will say hey can my
friend come in why don't you have both
of us
and she'll say oh i'm shy he's like
honey honey don't be shy and then his
friend comes in
and then the next guy comes in and now
it's three on one and she's like who am
i and she'll stink and then afterwards
they'll make jokes about her in front of
her
like oh look at this look at this look
at this and then she'll get embarrassed
and they they know what they're doing
you cannot tell these people who it's
their business
like if i'm gonna go to an investment
banker i'm the customer i'm gonna tell
him
no we're gonna negotiate he's gonna tell
me where to put my money
right you go to a chef you can tell him
how you want your steak but he's gonna
be the one to cook it
with these pinterests and these brothel
owners
you're not gonna these stripper club
owners you're not gonna tell them what
to do
you think because you're kind of like
attractive you got your long nails you
got your nice bag you wear all your
perfume you're gonna tell them how to do
it
honey they'll let you think it but they
got their
they got their pros so be safe islam
keeps you so
safe like if you keep your prayer times
it's not going to be time for you to do
that
i got to go to salah i got to purify
myself i have to wash my makeup
off i have to do soul i have to hang
around righteous people i need to listen
to some scholars
i need to study the quran softens your
heart
i wear the hijab the nikab right the
himar
these things are like medicine for you
and are of protection
and birds of a feather flock together
you cannot be a good muslim
and hang around these sexy brothel types
it's just
that's the pedal of the occultists i
mean it's hard for people to understand
because maybe they had good parents
the rebellious aspect comes in i wanna
rebel if you wanna rebel
okay they're gonna show you how to rebel
but guess what you'll rebel
and then you will be repelled as soon as
you're kind of tossed up you're a little
bit chewed up
yeah i think you are cut out
oh oh no thoughts
there we go there we go she's back i'm
sorry
do you want me to continue where i was
yeah for sure
okay sorry so so the beauty will
eventually get sucked out
the beauty will eventually leave and
then that's when it comes
forward when you're no longer your
beautiful girl you started out when you
did only fans
you were 22 you had that you had the
energy the
the your hormones are there but the
drugs have taken a chemical toll on your
body
and then you're 31 then the wrinkles
are gonna start to come on your face and
then you want a baby
but your body may your fertility is low
and you have a high body count and you
have a lot of baggage
a lot of mental baggage that a good man
is gonna be like whoa
geez like can you go to therapy and then
she goes to therapy and then she goes
and whines about all her trauma from bad
customers to her therapist
and it's like geez who wants to have a
kid with with
you know it's like you cannot tell these
pimped dresses
and these these customers what to do
that's not the business
they they that's what the feminists and
these liberals lie about like
i'm 15 minutes away from broadway where
that's the strip club area
that's right in san francisco right
there uh when i go to richmond to buy
burritos there's prostitutes everywhere
right the the glamorized prostitute
culture
is very rare for very few and all those
stripper ladies
when you see them in their 40s they
they're they're crazy
they get to be 50 years old it's gone
they're like in the bars they're smoking
cigarettes playing pool
their breasts have sag they ran out of
money
you know a good man's like hey i heard
about her like
you're going to ruin your own reputation
stay on the straight path worship allah
love your own skin love who you are
be good to your man honor your man be
happy with a small body count you don't
need to
vampirize men in order to get energy
from them
you know a matriarchy that these
feminists want
it's not going to be what you think it's
not going to be this utopia we're all
brushing each other's hair
and you know like all the women are nice
to each other
patriarchy is better because they will
protect us
keep us safe give us healthy children
and healthy male energy that is
protected from the vampiristic
brothel industry the jinn the occult the
darkness of that aim
because that'll also feminize men you
know that occultist energy
also busts out men to where they become
bisexual
feminized men who can be mounted anytime
and that is not something islamic islam
does not have that and
the male islamic energy that i have come
to know
it's not going to agree with the liberal
feminist utopia
or the atheist utopia everyone be like
bonobos
we have communes where we all raise each
other's kids we swap partners
we use drugs to loosen up we create
artificial wombs
no you know it's completely different so
if you're a muslim girl
and you're being tempted you are not
stronger than these professionals
they are professionals that's their job
look at the bull for example just look
at a bull if a bull can be mastered and
be ridden on by a cowboy
what makes you think as a girl that
you're going to tell a brothel owner
what to do
if the strongest animal can be submitted
you can too so don't get your ego
boosted
by your makeup the music your jewelry
your perfume
your car that's all material garbage
they know how to get inside of your head
they're professionals you think the like
a lot of the girls think because they
have material objects they'll have the
energy the power of their soul to
withstand corruption
no honey that's the way in they know how
to play with you
in ways they don't these girls don't
even understand don't let them in
stay away from those women be happy with
who you
are the the plainness the minimalism
will keep you safe islam will keep you
safe
and i know from experience those women
don't end well
you don't end well you think you're
gonna have stories to tell other girls
while you're hanging out on brunch oh i
did this i did that
it's all gonna come back in your dreams
it's gonna be with you when you go to
work and you
think that images come in your head
you're gonna want the images to go away
but you let it in it's there forever
and they say well i need pills from a
psychologist i need this and then the
pills have their own side effects
it's just your body is gonna be one
messed up
circus party of jinns you know it's
really sad
it's really sad women women are always
like like today the modern woman is on
this
train that you know oh we don't speak
bad about other women
kind of like men it's usually easy for
us to nitpick and
and if a guy's not on his stuff we tell
them straight up like as it is
but women naturally they don't like that
they have the sisterhood feminist type
of
community this collective where it's
like oh we don't want to speak bad we
don't judge you know we'll let them do
whatever
every girl girl power whatever this that
this is what i hear
and you know my problem with this is how
are you going to improve if no one holds
you accountable right
the stuff sister milan is talking about
it's no other girl is going to say it as
it is
and it's not going to be as bad in every
case
but it always starts with oh i'm just
gonna you know go outside just
for some mail gaze oh i'm just gonna go
to the club you know
i don't i'm not going to the club for
attention right i'm just gonna go to the
club
or hey you know i'm just gonna post this
on instagram
i know that voice inside me is telling
me i shouldn't i'm just gonna do that
anyway
or hey what's what's wrong with homie
fans i'm not doing
porn right he's just only fans i'm just
you know guys are dumb enough to pay for
it so why not
monopolize that right right but see
that's the thing is like
they say the men are dumb to monopoly to
monetize them
you already started that's it right
there you're already turning men into an
atm
you're already disrespecting them and
then when they're gonna come and
disrespect you treat you like a piece of
meat they complain
that's how it starts it starts with well
i'm hot so why not make money and rob
man of their money
you already started the process that is
on islamic that's unholy
you cannot treat men like that you treat
men like that
he has a reason to not want to treat you
well he has a reason to be like you know
what
you're going to talk to me like that
you're going to treat me like that okay
you can play this game
and the men are always going to be
superior at doing it to women
always men is going to win in that area
and the thing is is these girls say
don't hold me accountable
these pimples they'll fight you too the
other strippers though the prostitutes
do you think they're going to be nice to
you all the time they'll put bleach in
your shampoo
they'll rub their like all the things
that these women will do if they get
more customers
they'll be mean to you as well oh my
gosh the fighting that can happen
backstage
the fighting that happens between girls
like if another girl says i like this
guy
and he always goes to you instead of me
oh i hate you
they'll do pranks on you they'll put
garlic in your milk they'll do like
pranks on you if you're inside the
brothel house or they'll purposely
make you go with a very violent customer
they'll set you up
it's like there's no sisterhood amongst
prostitutes among strippers you think
they're gonna be like
oh no power no that's that's a facade
oh my gosh and those women don't really
know how to fight
but man they'll slice each other's faces
up
when they have their um their makeup
mirrors
the the way they thought they're like oh
she has this she has that
the gossiping starts oh look at her she
should work out more she's ah
oh she's oh no and then you'll be hurt
by the other women too
see that's what those girls forget don't
judge no there should be a strong woman
there
to snatch you up and say what are you
doing get your damn clothes on
get home what are you doing here get on
like a shepherd like
be strong because that pinterest you
don't make her her money
you think you're not gonna give her her
cut a real pinterest is gonna harm you
um do you think like when women are not
okay with patriarchy or they have this
sick
idea of men in their head do you think
that they're coming from a hurt place
well yeah because they've had a bad
relationship where there was like a bro
meathead maybe who cheated on them
they felt insecure so they said you know
what i'm never gonna be hurt again so
i'm gonna be the one who hurts them
first
or closes my heart that way i'll never
get hurt again not true
you're gonna meet a good guy and he
might have genuine feelings for you
but you've been so cold and you allowed
yourself to be played
like a fiddle and then you're more cold
and he's gonna be like you know what
you're so cold and nasty
you got this edge on your shoulder for
every dude i'm out of here because
there's going to be a calm muslim girl
who's going to be like hi i'll make you
cookies i'll bake you bread
i'll cook you dinner i'll help you with
your laundry who doesn't want that
she may be an 8 and not at 12 but the 12
is lazy doesn't cook doesn't clean will
spend all your money on
unnecessary crap always wants to go out
always wants attention on her
doesn't feed your soul i mean
it's natural for men to be like okay i'm
gonna get bored
of this sexy lady after the sixth time
right after you've already tasted the
ice cream
you're gonna start to be like you know i
kind of want to have children
and this chick doesn't want to settle
down so maybe i'll go with an eight
and then those girls become even more
bitter and then they're like okay well
since no guy wants me i'll monetize
myself even more
and then that's how you get even more
deep yeah and then
i mean it's intense the psychology
behind it is real and
as i'm saying like these liberal
feminists if you really listen to them
as i'm around them because i live in
california
and the bay area they think because they
have their their toys
they think because they have you know
the music the lights the costumes
because there's a lot of shops you know
you can go and buy stuff
choke colors whatever they want but
that's somehow going to protect them
or help them find the right guy but the
more perverted you get
and the more perverted the man is the
less safe your kids are around those
guys
because those guys are very dangerous
men a lot of them
are very open to abusing children
or making animals mixed in
once you start on a very perverted path
it only goes more
an honest sex workers will tell you this
but they don't want to damage their
client base and a pinterest
won't tell you much about the dangers
why
that's like a ship saying hey i might
undercook the chicken and poison you but
you want to buy the chicken
he's like the chef isn't going to tell
you about his potential mistakes
right he's going to say no no no we
always have organic
we always have this we always have that
we're so strict a pinterest and a
brothel keeper
a pimp on the street they're not gonna
tell you always the dangers they might
give you a little bit like oh have a
safe word
uh here's the number to call uh
and then they'll say oh well
prostitution became legal they argue
men would be more afraid to commit such
perverted acts which is not true because
even when my mom was an escort and these
men
are dropping hardcore cash plenty
the old cliche of women being left in
dumpsters is
is like you think these epstein island
types
they can't pay a lawyer to just dispose
of you
you know it's like these women are very
dumb they think because
if they go to an expensive customer that
they'll be safe
no no no no that just means he has more
money to dispose of you
you didn't want to do something they're
afraid you'll talk to the police they
will get rid of you
and they will send women to send you a
message as well
these women are not smart they're being
brainwashed by music videos
and it all starts with taking off the
clothes piece by piece take off your
hijab
put on this halter top oh now make it
more sexy show more
show this the male gaze is addicting
because it gives you validation
it's once you let it in it's like a wave
a surfer you got to be a surfer how many
surfers crash
they fall in the water and there's
sharks in the water these men will feed
on you so hard and stalk you
when you get like and some girls think
oh well they won't find out my real
identity yes they can
it's so easy now to find out who people
are they can find where you live
you can find where you work he can find
you it's so easy now to find people in
the digital age
if these dudes show up at your home
you're gonna be afraid
oh i'll call the police they'll they
will stalk you my mom told me that
she had to deal with so many stalkers
male customers who were so addicted that
they would go to her car
they'd leave her notes on her car leave
flowers on her car leave her
watches leave her shoes these men
once they've had you some of them won't
go away
and you're gonna have to move you're
gonna have to change your name
you know it's gonna be quite difficult i
wanna i wanna hear what
brother angela and rami has to say and
to be honest it sounds extreme to a lot
of our viewers but it's like
the the road that sister milan is
painting for us depicting for us it only
leads that way
and when you're one or two or three
paces that direction
you might think okay i have the uncle to
like restrain myself
i'm not gonna be like every other girl
i'm not gonna go that far but it's like
my guy
oh my god the road only leads that way
so why are you even walking that way you
know what i mean like
you're just being stupid yes yeah
and
that's so okay so this is uh this is
really good stuff
and it gives people insight into
this type of life because this is not
something that many people know about
so the one thing that i want to do here
is i want to kind of restructure this
and bring it into um
more so for muslim women here right
because let's be honest a lot of the
muslim women are being affected
by feminism they're being affected by
uh liberalism and just all these
different
ideologies and ways of doing things
right and with that being said you have
the traditional values in islam
that are actually starting to be tossed
to the side by many of these muslim
women
for example there's a lot of muslim
women
that are completely against collision
even though clearly it says it
in the quran you got a lot of muslim
women
who they they literally just want a man
that's going to take care of everything
for them but they
are trying to one up and um kind of like
you said
it's a very domineering
type relationship where the woman is a
masculine and the man isn't
feminine and what's crazy is that the
the woman
will actually want this because of the
ideology that's being instilled
upon her because of the things that
she's putting on to herself
thinking that this is correct so
for these chicks what do you have to say
for that you don't
feel like it's a burden to take care of
your mom
because deep down you care about your
mom you wouldn't want to see her
in this position you wouldn't want to
see her suffer because no one else is
going to take care of her
but i mean simply just tell you yeah
you're sitting like no
how would you feel if mom passed away
knowing you didn't do anything to take
care of her
[Music]
[Music]